[Music]
hey you guys here i am again in my naked
ass room doing another book review uh i
think that probably as far as the
recorded stuff goes um this one and i
think there'll be one more
uh recorded review that will be in this
naked room uh but hopefully from then on
i'll have a nice background in the back
because if you're new here and you've
never seen any of my videos before uh
normally i have like a really cool
background with a bunch of books and
cool lights and everything like that but
i'm in the middle of moving so this is
my old studio and i haven't got the new
studio set up yet so that's why the
background looks like ass just you know
thought i would explain to everybody so
the book i'm talking about today was one
that i was highly highly anticipating
this was a book it came out back in
summer of 2020 in hardback and i don't
normally uh
think about buying hardbacks because
they're super expensive and unless i get
the you know super cheap ones uh at
barnes noble or something but i actually
did think about it in this regard
because it was a lot of buzz about it it
was like on the new york times
bestseller list it was all kind of a
book club selection and all this other
kind of stuff and it sounded super super
cool because i really really like
gothic horror like gothic literature and
this seemed right up my alley and i saw
a lot of really positive reviews of it
on uh several horror channels that i
watch now i did actually eventually end
up waiting too long or waiting too long
waiting uh until it came out of
paperback and i actually bought this
paperback in a barnes noble like for the
first time i'd been to one like in a
really long time
and i bought this one and one other one
that i'm gonna review later but this is
mexican gothic
by sylvia moreno garcia now as i said
this came out in 2020 the paperback i
guess came out like pretty recently and
this book has been compared to
everything from rebecca by daphne du
maurier uh it's been called it's sort of
like lovecraft inspired it's sort of poe
inspired it's a bit like jane eyre it's
kind of like a modern take well not that
modern because it's actually set in 1950
but it's kind of a modern take on the
gothic horror novel and i have to say i
absolutely loved this book i just
thought it was so just the whole
atmosphere of it because like i said i
love all those tropes i love creepy old
crumbling mansions and family secrets
and curses and all that kind of stuff i
love that kind of [ __ ] you know
cemeteries and uh so this was just right
and this just hit all my all of my love
buttons as far as like books go so you
pretty much i mean unless this like was
really really badly written which it's
not it's actually really awesomely
written uh you know i was probably gonna
love it and indeed i do now i guess
sylvia moreno garcia this might be i
don't know if this is like her third
album she's written a few novels
beforehand she does uh some stuff for
npr as well she wrote actually a couple
of cool essays i don't know if they're
in the hardback or not there's a couple
essays like about gothic horror in
general there's like an interview with
her there's book club stuff in the back
of the paperback and there's also um an
excerpt from another novel or another
short story in the back so you actually
get a lot of stuff with this
so the story
centers around our protagonist
as i said it's set in 1950 now at the
beginning our protagonist whose name is
noah me i guess i'm pronouncing that
correctly i hope she's kind of like a
wealthy socialite like me like in her
early 20s very modern woman you know
she's kind of a fashion plate she's sort
of you know flirtatious and she's not
really worried about you know marriage
or getting tied down or being
traditional or anything like that she
kind of likes to go out and party and
have a good time and everything so she's
still living in her father's house and i
guess her father's you know family is
very wealthy now when she was growing up
uh she lives in mexico city by the way
when she was growing up uh her best
friend was her cousin catalina so
they've kind of kept in touch over the
years like with letters and everything
but very recently catalina has married
this english guy named virgil doyle and
he has taken her away to this
crumbling
mance called high place which is sort of
like in this remote area of hidalgo i
think like where there was a bunch of
silver mines back in the day
and that was indeed where the doyle
family got most of their uh tr like most
of their money from like from the silver
mines but they've been kind of on hard
times a little bit because the silver
mines closed after the revolution and
all this other kind of stuff so it goes
like a little bit into the history of it
but it's not like you know this is
mostly like a very very story-based
creepy
gothic thing it goes like a lot into
you know the kind of not the history of
the area but it does give you enough
context uh that you'll kind of like you
know understand what's going on
so at the beginning of the book noami's
father gets a letter from catalina and
the letter is really really weird like
catalina is in there basically saying my
husband is trying to poison me um and
saying weird stuff about things in the
walls um you know so she sounds like
she's kind of losing her marbles a
little bit
so the dad is like super worried and
also uh noah me like i said this is like
her best friend when she was growing up
it's her cousin and she's like yeah that
doesn't sound too good does it
so either she needs a psychiatrist or
something really bad's going on
so
noamy's dad decides to send her to this
house to see what's what it's like you
know if we need to bring her back to
mexico city for a little while if this
is not a good marriage if this doyle
family is like [ __ ] her over we need
to figure out what's going on so he
sends his daughter because he figures
you know she's really good at kind of
diplomacy i guess and because she uh she
and catalina were so close um they're
you know he's hoping that she'll be able
to like kind of smooth things over in a
way that maybe wouldn't if if he went
instead
so she goes to this place as i said this
mansion that's called high place where
the doyle family lives
and catalina is there with her husband
virgil
virgil also has a half i think it's his
half brother named francis and then
there's also a woman who i think is
francis's mom that's florence
and then there's like this really really
old like ancient
mummy-like looking dude named howard who
was kind of like the patriarch of the
family and then there's like a bunch of
servants now this mansion
is
clearly uh has seen better days as i
said it's this is set in 1950 um at some
point the the doyle's owned like a bunch
of silver mines they had all of these
you know kind of employees and like you
know workers that you know from the area
that lived around there or and worked in
there but after the silver mines closed
up they lost a lot of their fortune so
the house is kind of in shitty condition
now nomi shows up and immediately uh
there's some pretty
unsettling [ __ ] going on in this house
in the sense of
florence in particular who was francis's
mom is she virgil's mom too i can't
remember because it's like there's
there's so much like weird family stuff
going and i won't
if i go too much into it it'll kind of
like spoil all the stuff that's going on
in the family so i'm trying not to so
we'll just say florence she's she's at
least francis's mom i can't remember
she's also virgil's mom
but she's just like this really really
proper basically she comes across at
first like she thinks noah me is
i don't know i don't know if i'd call it
but she thinks she's like too modern
she's one of those promiscuous flighty
kind of girls and it's like they have
all these rules in this house like
you're not allowed to smoke which no me
is like that's some [ __ ] right there
because she really really likes to smoke
like when you have dinner with the
family no one's allowed to talk it's
just kind of like all this really creepy
[ __ ] and noah me is just kind of like
yeah i don't like this situation all
that much
and the weird thing too is that when she
goes to talk to catalina
catalina is in bed and the family says
oh she has tuberculosis and she's
supposed to be resting and so you can't
really go up into her room and visit her
too much because you know you'll wear
her out and all the social we're taking
care of her we have a doctor that comes
every week to check her out named dr
cummins everything's fine why did you
even come here um so basically she's
like well hey like you know she sent me
this crazy letter and the family just
kind of
writes that off there's kind of like
well you know she has tb and she was
having a fever and she was having
delusions so maybe she wrote the letter
you know in the midst of those delusions
and you know you're worrying about
nothing because as you can see now
you're fine and it does seem that when
she goes to talk to catalina catalina's
like oh yeah that was so silly i don't
even remember what i wrote i must have
been feverish or something like that
but you're pretty uh it's it's pretty
immediately clear
that
catalina is not really allowed to speak
freely particularly around uh the other
family members um so you're not really
entirely sure what the [ __ ] is going on
so
after that like they kind of
will know me is like well okay well i
think something weird is going on so i'm
not gonna leave her here because like as
she you know that's my cousin that's my
best friend you know we grew up together
she's like so i can't leave without
figuring out what's going on so she
starts doing all these things that
the other family members in this creepy
old house are just like cannot like put
up because the great thing about like no
me is such like a great character
because like i said she's kind of she's
very young like she's only in her 20s
but she's kind of like um very socially
adept uh you know she's a socialite
she's you know she she's very nicely
dressed she's very sophisticated and
she's used to
pretty much getting her way like she
doesn't like this oh you have to submit
you have to like play by our rules and
she's like nah i'm not having that so um
you know she's like this is my cousin
she's my family member she's my best
friend i'm gonna figure out like what is
best for her
you know not you guys who just kind of
like came there later and so she starts
doing [ __ ] like you know she'll she goes
to another doctor like to get a second
opinion uh she starts going into town
which after a while they say she's not
allowed to do that anymore like she's
not allowed to go into town so she has
to like sneak off and then like she
starts getting into trouble for like
breaking all their rules so they're
basically trying to make her into a
prisoner in the same way that they sort
of have made catalina into a prisoner
under the guise of oh she has
tuberculosis and she can't go outside
and blah blah and all this other kind of
stuff if i say too much about this
because okay so like the first probably
half to three quarters of this book is
just this kind of stuff like knowing me
trying to
see what the hell is going on with
catalina what the hell is going on with
this family why are they all so weird
what's going on with this house because
she starts having uh really weird
nightmares that seem more like visions
she does have actual waking visions like
hallucinations in the house like she
sees
like mold like moving on the walls and
things like that she starts sleepwalking
again which she hadn't done since she
was a child so obviously
you know the house is haunted or
something is going on and i all i'll say
about that is that
the house is sort of haunted but it's
not a traditional hotting
and
i really really liked the sort of like
originality of how the haunting or the
curse or whatever you want to call it
was manifesting it was like
i was like it's something that you don't
that that wasn't really in a lot of
books you know what i'm saying it's just
so i just thought it was like a really
cool concept uh but that's all that i'm
gonna say it's kind of it's kind of like
an original concept not completely
original because nothing is but one that
you don't see very much and i thought
that was like really cool now
interestingly
the doyle family even though the town
like the remote town where this book is
set
uh is not a real town the author sylvia
moreno garcia did base it on a real
place the place was called real del
monte
and it was i guess it was up in the
hills it was a silver mine and actually
over time because there were so many
silver mines there and all these brits
came and set up silver mines or like ran
silver mines there so they brought in
all these british workers and mexican
workers from the local area um
indigenous people that worked there and
it was like you know the conditions were
horrible uh so it was this kind of whole
like uh history about it in this area
there were so many british people living
there at the time um that it was called
little cornwall
so that's kind of like what that's kind
of where um she sort of got the idea for
this village and this english family
who are living in
this remote part of mexico where they
used to have a silver mine but it's like
it's really interesting because that was
like a part of the history i didn't know
a great deal about like i said it's not
the the story's not like bogged down
with all these like historical details
you know what i mean it's not like you
know a james michener kind of thing or
anything like that where it's just kind
of like all of this detail but there's
enough detail in there that gives you
like a really nice like it weaves a
really nice context like around this
story and the interesting thing too is
that
the doyle family are english and they're
all kind of like really really pale and
really weird and especially the
patriarch howard who's kind of like this
really really he
the way she described him i kind of
thought of like grandpa from the texas
chainsaw massacre because she said he
looked like ancient like it looked like
a [ __ ] mummy or something and there's
some really gross [ __ ] like with him
later on like as he's getting sicker and
sicker some of this stuff uh in toward
the end of the book gets like pretty
gross as far as like kind of body horror
type of stuff so you know know that
going in but like i said for the first
three quarters it's basically like a
gothic horror mystery you know haunted
house type of situation and then it kind
of goes almost i don't want to say
lovecraftian because that's going to
give people the wrong idea but it does
kind of go in like a weird
sort of
organic body horror sort of direction so
you know so like i said just kind of be
warned if you're grossed out easily
because some of the [ __ ] at the end is
like pretty gross but uh the patriarch
howard he you pretty much know he's
gonna be trouble like from the first
time you meet him like he comes down to
dinner and immediately starts talking
about like eugenics and all this other
kind of stuff and has superior races and
inferior races and all this other stuff
to which like knowing me is just like oh
boy like even in 1950 she was just kind
of like
yeah now so you know what i mean but
yeah so
if you really like like i said if you
like daphne du maurier if you like um
this has been compared to like uh
guillermo del toro's stuff as well which
i can kind of see that um because he
really likes a lot of gothic horror kind
of tropes as well it gave me yeah it
gave me like a little bit of like a
crimson peak kind of vibe like at the
beginning maybe if that sounds like
something that you would like like i
said it gets weird like at the end and
it's not
a ghost or a haunted house in the
traditional sense like the house is sort
of haunted or cursed
but not in the way that you might think
you know what i mean because like the
house has like a like a creepy history
like the family seems like it's kind of
cursed like there's like one of the one
of the relatives like back in the day
like shot
the whole like her whole family and then
herself and you know so there's other
kind of there's that kind of stuff going
on too and so a lot of the book is sort
of like knowing me like figuring out the
history of the house and figuring out
what the [ __ ] is going on with this
weird ass family fending off virgil who
was catalina's husband and it was also
like
a really creepy
aggressive douchebag and then and she
has this thing too where she's almost
kind of like simultaneously like
attracted to him and repelled by him at
the same time so there's that kind of
fascinating stuff too but she's just um
knowing me is just like a great uh
protagonist she's just so i think i saw
one review that called her spunky which
i don't know it seems like a little
reductive but i but i get what they're
getting at she's just like a very
she's kind of like a no-nonsense it's
weird because she's kind of like
you would think because she's this kind
of young fashion plate who kind of only
cares about partying but when she gets
to this place and there's a mystery to
be solved and catalina she thinks is in
danger she steps right up and is just
kind of like yeah i'm gonna like try and
figure this out and like sort it out and
um as i said she's very used to
kind of getting her way not not in a
like a babyish like kind of like i need
my way kind of thing but she's very um
she's very used to like getting what she
wants and knowing how to get what she
wants like through social interaction
and things like that so it's really
interesting to see her and this weird
ass family kind of like butting heads
like through the whole thing like it's
all this kind of family drama but yeah i
was really really into this book as i
said if you like gothic literature of
any kind whether it's you know jane
austen for everything from jane austen
to guillermo del toro then you would
probably love this i thought it was
great oh and also i want to show you
this i don't know if they had this in
the hardback but look at this you guys
look i'm sorry if you're just listening
to the audio look at that
that's like the inner fly leaf i love
that i just i want that like on a poster
to like put
you know what i mean to put on my wall
because that is like a beautiful
beautiful piece of art i'm not really
sure who did that yeah that's an amazing
piece of artwork and i love it so much
but yeah this was a great book i can see
why i got
all the accolades and anything and
everything like that so i would
definitely definitely recommend it if
you're into that kind of literature you
will probably love it just like i did
and that will do it for this tomes of
terror and i will see you guys on the
next one bye